-Guys, it's time for
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
Here we go.
-♪ Hashtags ♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
♪♪
-Now, we do this thing every
week where I send out a hashtag
and ask you guys
to respond to that topic.
This week I sent out
the hashtag #WhyImSingle,
and I asked you guys to tweet
a funny, weird, or embarrassing
reason why you're single.
Within minutes, it was
a trending topic in the U.S.,
so thank you for playing along.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And I hope y'all find love.
But this is -- Now I thought
I'd share some of my favorite
#WhyImSingle tweets
from you guys.
This one is from @StayBarefoot.
They say...
[ Laughter ]
"Mooooo!"
-"Mooooo!"
-This one is from @ryanrawlings.
He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Not gonna be a second date,
is there? Okay, I love you."
This one's from
@NotFunnyFrancis. They say...
[ Laughter ]
I think you're dating
the wrong people.
I think it's cool
that you do that.
-Finger hats.
-Yeah, you got to make
those hats on your fingers.
Come on.
This one's from @ReneeJordan78.
She said...
[ Laughter ]
-That's not her.
That's why he's single, yeah.
It's not why you're single.
This one's from @vashokananth.
He says...
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. Done deal.
-Yeah, why not, man?
This one is from
@whitedaisies07. She says...
[ Laughter ]
Supposably.
-Supposably.
-Supposably. Yep.
This one's from @SabinaEGarcia.
She says...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Ohh.
-Yeah.
-Come on.
-And Hallmark movies.
And Hallmark movies. Yeah.
He's a prince.
-Hm!
-This one's from @DunLahfAtMae.
-DunLahfAtMae?
-"Dun Lahf At Mae."
-Mae. [ Laughs ]
-DunLahfAtMae.
-DunLahfAtMae!
-Suh!
-She says...
[ Laughter ]
[ Cymbals crash ]
-"I guess like this?"
-This last one is from
@charley-ck14. She says...
There you have it. Those are our
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out
more of our favorites,
you can go to
tonightshow.com/hashtags.
Stick around. We're playing
charades with Cara Delevingne
and Neil Patrick Harris
when we come back.